just the detail the setup of everything
yeah I first seen [ __ ] Rama's brother
who is a main character in the first one
gets just [ __ ] his head shot right in
the vaccine open it and that's like
powerful ray too and it's not like the
Ray - whoa it's like the Ray - oh she's
just God we mean business
yeah this is intense man and I just love
the build-up there is a lot of story at
one point like there's no action for a
while it's at one point and it is just a
lot mainly story because you get that
you you they have to set up because this
movie does go a lot of places and there
is that sort of you gotta infiltrate the
group first and that's gonna take some
time yeah so the the build-up to it by
the time it got to that focus one thing
with the first raid was I felt I became
a little immune to it the fight scenes
out because it was like okay as a cool
action scene yeah but then in this one
it was like every time an action scene
came in it was intense as fun it was it
was felt different always a different
setting always different feel to it the
characters were in a different world
basically with each fight see something
I really applaud with this movie it's
kind of small as a small detail though
is that he didn't for the whole movie
cliche
you know like think about his brother
the whole time oh yeah like it was a lot
of movies yeah when they have that sort
of thing happened the whole the whole
time it just keep they keep bringing
back memories of the brother like and if
that didn't happen I feel like that was
more real I was gonna be a simple
revenge movie based off the opening and
then it wasn't that at all oh yeah the
next step it's like here's what happened
after that guy from the first movie
[ __ ] everything up yeah what I really
appreciate about the action and like the
especially this last film it's so
stylistic yes yet it feels realistic at
the same time well because they told
this line between being hyper violent
and hyper stylized this movie is much
bloodier oh yeah definitely like there's
a lot of action in the raid but it's
there's not as much point-blank stuff so
you get to see like the aftermath of
things I never would have thought if you
would have told me there was more blood
in this one after watching the first
rate I would have been like what
how can there be more but no they're the
blood and the violence it feels even
more authentic this time around so
that's what makes it even more intense
yeah they didn't they didn't mess around
with playing with our heads making it
you know sugarcoating it all it was just
like right in your face this is what
just happen like wounds look like wounds
in this film if it feels realistic at
all it's because it's treated like
violence it's not treated like any kind
of fun in the first one it was just kind
of like defense but this one it was like
anger
oh yeah basically that's what made that
last by great yeah yes yeah that's true
this isn't just good versus evil I mean
this is like the reason for fighting is
so much more varied in this one and and
yeah you're dealing with a bunch of
people who don't have police protocol to
cling to even ramaa
you know who's undercover but still is
working for like the law he's in a
position where he can't play like a cop
so he honestly kept getting screwed over
there by the people he was working for
so a video just kept building up and
then like he just exploded and it's like
you work everyone in the theater because
when he goes to the prison he's always
opposed to be there for a few months and
then it cuts to two years later there
was like oh dude it was just a big
bummer two years it's like D 1/2 years
of your life right there man that sucks
all I kept thinking of it was I hope his
wife isn't cheating on because I would
suck to come home after all that and
she's asleep so you be gone for a while
yeah I'd have been dead what is it
anyway more can you really blame them in
that situation because it's like you
said you'd be gone a few months but you
couldn't tell me where it's been several
years now
yeah so Sally have you have you really
thought this through Sally because it
sounds like you haven't oh like ah I
would get if the girl did because she
has desires about desires man you've
been gone I thought you could be dead no
exactly but I thought you know my other
person was dead I'd like wait a while my
other person I ever sorry I thought my
people have been waiting in line this is
without a doubt the the first one and
the second one they're so different yet
that are both one of my favorite two of
my favorite action movies between the
two which one's better yeah it's like
they're very different but they still
feel like a logical progression from one
to the other quick
question guys I'm sure when you guys can
answer this for us was that mad dog is
an actor it's the same actor has to be
the same actor yeah because it is good
facts with Jerry that's what it is he's
not the same Carrie okay I was a little
confused yeah cuz I was like what dog
stole emember like how he died and I was
like wait there was no in the first
thing because I'm like there's no way he
goes around cuz I thought he came back
was like no that's not acceptable
even though I have to think about who
that character was I remember watching
that film and really liking this
character yeah like sigh he doesn't have
a lot of screen time necessarily you do
like sympathize for the guy like how do
you sympathize after him machete I did
this guy just you know he's like I'm
used to doing that if you can make a
person sympathize with a killer well you
you know you need to understand their
reasons at least you know it's like but
you know what it kind of reminded me of
was like the fact that you know his wife
is kind of dealing with what Rob was
dealing with yeah they're insane I meant
Rama's wife and Rama's wife are dealing
with the same thing and that's when I
was like whoa
just that [ __ ] final fight man was so
worth it okay that there were that great
who separate moments of applause in our
theatre okay there's the car chase one
that was it yeah and then there was oh
the fight scene between baseball guy and
hammer girl yeah yeah it was genius oh
my god it was oh dude it wasn't me the
other applause and then right at the end
the final fight - between him and the
main Japanese yeah yeah yeah that was a
great fight dude dude gosh I just for a
second I was hoping that you go or go or
whatever his name was was gonna either
commit suicide or apologize drama and
he's like I'm gonna kill you that's
another thing this movie has great
character to sense like sometimes not a
development it's like it's a descent
there there are more are there there's
more development more arc
yeah it's movie and I like that you you
weren't sure what they were gonna do
what the character was gonna do usually
movies are very predictable yeah oh dude
one [ __ ] uh the [ __ ] shot his dad I
was like oh
I didn't see that coming just murder
your father now is nuts
that kind of dissent it was like yeah
this guy is becoming what people fear he
could become and like Rama's development
throughout it's like I haven't enough is
enough he's so involved in this world
that's not even about what he first got
into it for it really is a damn good
script the best thing was the sound
device because that that's what caused
that day the amazing ending would be too
soft because it wasn't even remember it
was actually Rama's the he'd like put it
in his wallet but then he thought it was
oh he thought it was a pet oh yeah
wrecker bozo so it was a complete
accident
hey job Asia that was a great shot to
you but he takes a shot gun to his head
and then you just see the detail of it
and then it just lets the camera roll
for a while well yeah the thing is like
they didn't take the I'm gonna shoot you
in the face a pro it's like they took
the this is what happens when someone
gets shot point-blank with a shotgun in
the head every shot just had so much
tension in it it was it's a really
intense film and the thing is is they
keep the camera rolling and they don't
edit it immediately sometimes and so
it's it's kind of like scary like is
there anything else gonna happen like
but it doesn't but it it's perfect
the film's perfect last thing I got to
say about this movie with the action
especially what makes it even more
believable is when like even when Rama
gets hit or when he's chasing after a
guy or going after people and stuff like
you could tell he's been physically
damaged in some way yeah these people
like even if it's not realistic for them
to still be standing they look like [ __ ]
yeah they look like they feel care and
they get hit it's like they seem like
they really got hurt of that moment you
know yeah it's something that bothers me
and a lot of action films you know
they'll get hit in one scene in the next
scene that the cut doesn't look as bad
or totally make up with this one it just
I noticed that two I was like halfway
through some of those fights out like
wow they've gotten significantly
bloodier over the course of this or
sometimes they get their ass kicked in
two like in the [ __ ] face and then
like the next day there's like no
bruises or anything yeah it's like I got
a little smudge here but our cameras
about dizer to wrap this thing yeah so
guys what do you think are the reasons
to see this I would have to say reason
to see number one for me I would have to
say just it's the [ __ ] you know what
yeah well
anything there's everything yeah the
movie it's the reason movies are made
that you need just a reason action
movies are made yeah I'm sure okay
action great just that changes the story
the [ __ ] everything acting but
everything is bigger everything is more
expansive everything is if there's one
thing people will complain about with
the first rate was it's seen a lexing
some story but it's definitely delivers
on the action this one you cannot
[ __ ] say that now it delivers the
[ __ ] out of a story and it delivers the
[ __ ] out of the action man it's like one
of the best action movies of all time
you gotta watch yeah it's fantastic as
this movie is simply that certain of the
fight scenes you might have a little
trouble finding motivation why this
needed to happen but usually it's made
up for by ingenuity alone you know and
the cool thing is that it's two and a
half hours and it doesn't feel like it's
too long no no no it was perfect moves
just right it's like the actions
incredible cinematography is incredible
cast is great the story is even bigger
the music is great the effects are great
the direction is really confident and
stylish you know it's it's great
everything is awesome everything is a
like if the lego movie was hyper all
right guys thanks for checking out our
review for the Ray to Brendan Fraser why
don't you go ahead scroll that comment
box below and tell us who's celebrity
asks do you want to get Claire enough
and once you're done with that why don't
you come over here and click this button
or wherever it is it's in the center
Jerry the click that button and you can
see more episodes of reasons to see cuz
we've seen other movies believe it and
believe it or not ripley believes it
last but not least if you want to get
updated every time one of our reviews or
videos is out subscribe click on Sally's
head right here subscribe to my channel
right there by her boobage she hasn't
that's the link yeah yeah right there
yeah this remove [ __ ] movie makes you
want to [ __ ] people up it really does
make you I want to fight someone how
long to the theater punching you in the
face yeah you did it was really sweet of
you you know what happened while we were
watching the movie and earthquakes
to mention that it was scary though some
was kicking my seat I was about to be
like oh we won't fight Sally was ready
to stab someone multiple times in the
same spot it was crazy
Rama blacked out because he got hit too
hard at one point really like during
shooting yeah wow yeah man it was crazy
he deserves an Oscar he deserves an
Oscar he's a great actor and fighter you
know that scene where he got naked I do
what if he had an erection when that was
happening that's why he looks so nervous
yeah you know what's crazy about Rama's
body he wasn't to cut but you're like
he's the most lethal weapon out there
expecting like at least AB yeah what the
thing is like it's it's not even about
control and it's all defense and it's
all force that you that's how I work and
generated this Shh
what and it's like you know they've said
like the dudes who are really muscular
and stuff like that are not necessarily
the best for that kind of a fight you
know it's like it's about lean muscle
about you know being able to be quick
and use your weight so I get both of you
up so I like yeah it's like it seems to
make sense that an insane fighter like
that would not be fun buff you know yeah
we said yeah together
jeah isn't that adorable big marry
bruise any marry tomorrow guys we're
getting married
halli marry what it just jinx James Bond
character Shelly knows almost its own
franchise
don't worry not a lot people get there
I've managed to make both of you feel
students noting that it's jinx Pokemon
hey pokemons gosh
you